[Music]
hi there very good evening you of course
are watching The Press previewer first
look at what's going to be on the front
pages of tomorrow's papers as they
arrive here at Sky News and time to see
what's making headlines with Fleet
Street Fox and Daily Mirror columnist
Susie Boniface we're also joined by the
editor of the Jewish Chronicle Jake
Wallace Simons as you can see they're
joining me now and they are with us from
till midnight tonight both of you
welcome to Sky News thank you so much
for joining us before we speak to them
in more detail let's get you up to date
what's on the front pages of the
newspapers tomorrow war hero takes aim
at Harry over kill claims reads the
front of the times as they look at
backlash at the Duke of sussex's face
since he said in his Memoir he killed 25
people while serving in Afghanistan well
the same story is uncovered by The Daily
Mirror tomorrow the headline Harry faces
Global Fury over Taliban kill claims and
Harry kills outrage reads the Daily
Mirror tomorrow the prince also covers
front of the Daily Telegraph but this
time in terms of his late grandmother
its headline reads Harry's ambushes
harmed the Queen's Health Harry also on
the front story of the express tomorrow
and in other news tomorrow revealed
abramovich's trust transferred before
sanctions reads the front of the
Guardian newspaper sonak invites union
leaders to talks as the headline of the
financial times tomorrow as it looks at
the prime minister's ongoing struggle
with strike action and British national
security fears after Chinese spyware
found in government car in the UK reads
the front of the eye weekend
and of course a quick reminder for you
that by scanning the QR card that you
can see on the screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you watch with
us
well joined of course by Fleet Street
Fox and Daily Mirror columnist Susie
Boniface and the editor of the Jewish
Chronicle Jake Wallace Simons welcome to
you both good to have you on board let's
start with the Daily Mail why don't we
Harry faces Global Fury over those
Taliban kill claims Susie what do you
make of it
um well it's it's just insane is all I
can say before I start I'd like to say
I'd like to thank some one of our
regular Sky News viewers bright guy
called Brian Pitt who served at the
nuclear tests in 1956-195 operation
grapple he sent me a Memento of those
tests which is on my door behind me at
the moment it's a pennant from Christmas
Island and he very kindly sent it to me
to add to my Nuclear door and that's an
actual pennant there that came from the
Britain's nuclear testing program so
thank you Brian for sending it to me
please don't anybody remember the stuff
it's not going up on the wall
but as far as the Daily Mail is
concerned this is the an astonishing
contortion from a newspaper which spent
years actual years campaigning to
overturn the criminal conviction of a
soldier who was accused of murdering one
Taliban Sergeant Alexander Blackman uh
whose conviction later was reduced to
manslaughter for the diminished
responsibility but Scott had to serve a
seven year sentence for it
um to somehow say in Daily Mail world
that killing more Taliban in a way that
was legal is somehow worse
um it's kind of astonishing now it may
well be and of course it is there are
many uh people who are quoted former
military commanders Pilots colleagues of
Harry's who have said this isn't quite
what you should be doing we don't come
home and announce our totals uh your
average veteran in the street who
respected Harry a lot up till now
because he served May well feel that's
not the kind of thing he would do when
he comes home and it's on the sofa with
his wife he's not going out how many
people he's killed or thinks he's killed
and it's not quite right but every
single member of the military who's
written a book has written in detail
about the deaths they um carried out
that Andy McNabb uh the Bravo 2-0 guys
they have all written about the people
they've killed you may not have
announced a big total but they have gone
into some detail about it so the fact
that Harry has somehow said he's killed
25
It's Not Unusual and it's not the kind
of thing that in any other circumstance
The Daily Mail would have any problem
with whatsoever just for the matters of
being balanced uh your paper The Daily
Mirror also calls it an outrage the fact
that Harry has has given this number and
it has to be said I mean let's let's
come to you as well Jake you're looking
at the Times indeed most of the front
pages it seems that most people have a
problem with this don't they the times
quotes a war hero taking aim at Harry
over this this kill claim it does seem
to be not not the dumb thing for people
of the Armed Forces to talk about how
many people they've killed what's your
view
that's why I think I think Susie's being
very unfair to the Daily Mail in her
criticism of it uh the male was not
criticizing uh Prince Harry for killing
the enemy that's what he's there for as
a as a as a soldier as an Airman uh they
were criticizing the fact that he um
openly bragged about the number the kill
total or the kill tally that's quite
different from soldiers sometimes
telling their War Stories and their
Memoirs he's got a sense of uh sort of
boasting of Jubilation of as Colonel Tim
Collins put it notches on a rifle but
now all of us who know soldiers in our
daily lives I think most of the uh
viewers will know soldiers personally
will know they very very rarely talk
about their War experiences at all and
certainly never ever talk about the the
people they've killed and certainly not
the numbers of people they've killed and
they're very very good reasons for that
uh Colonel Tim Collins
um was quoted in the times uh today uh
as saying that Harry has not only
betrayed his birth family but he's also
now betrayed his military family those
are strong strong words I'm such a
senior military figure and he's the the
man uh you might remember who gave that
very inspiring pre-battle uh pep talk to
troops before the Iraq invasion where he
told them not to be too enthusiastic in
killing or they would bring shame upon
themselves and their families and you
know I've got uh friends you know who
are Afghans who've translated for I had
one friend who translated for the then
Prince Charles in Afghanistan and he's
told me that his family have been put at
risk in Afghanistan by further apprisal
attacks based on a response to Harry's
brag that's gone all around the world
whichever way you cut it it's wrong it's
not about the Daily Mail every single
Paper has taken the same view it's
totally wrong and against the military
code and must be condemned quick comment
before we move on Susie very quick
comment yeah I agree to some extent I
think that yeah the announcing of a
total as I said in my piece is not that
common and I think it's probably unwise
of Harry to have done it but the
criticism of him for discussing this
kind of stuff I think is unbalanced I
think the male's attitude is a bit
strange okay um
has been before and I wouldn't say it
was bragging if you read the bit of that
that part of the book that's been uh
reproduced he's very clear that he's
neither boastful nor regretful about
okay on to uh the telegraph now that
they take a different angle uh Harry's
Ambush is harmed the Queen's Health they
say according to Royal sources it's
those sources again huh uh sources close
to the former Monarch say that Prince
Harry's repeated ambushing at the royal
family had a detrimental effect on the
Queen Elizabeth's second Health in her
final year uh what do you make of the
line that they're taking on this Saga
Susie you go first
uh well I take it with a big deep pinch
of salt and if you read into the the
story it appears to come from someone
who was perhaps linked to the late Queen
perhaps worked for her as a friend of
her and there's a very uh hyperbolic
statement in the second column then
which they talk about Harry
um saying he wants a reconciliation but
then he puts this machete in their backs
now that is a very very strong choice of
a turn of phrase and I would have
thought if Harry or Megan had come out
with a phrase claiming that their family
has somehow put a machete in their backs
about something in this brow the
telegraph would say that was ridiculous
thing to suggest
um the queen was very elderly she was
obviously not in the best of health this
can't have helped or but I'm sure as
well she was being well insulated from
it and from the reports that came out of
the meetings that were taking place
during the family the conflict and the
the bad bits the stressful bits were
very much things that took place between
the princesses rather than with their
grandmother so and Jake I mean Harry has
said an awful lot has no excuse me about
so-called Royal sources sources close to
the royal family I mean could this be an
example of that again
well one of the ways in which Royal the
Royals work is that they brief stuff out
anonymously a lot via sources most of
it's um accurate and has come from come
from the the real sources themselves is
that the right way to go forward do you
think
well I mean it is part of the tradition
of how the Royals are they they try to
remain aloof and certainly in terms of
on the record comments they try to weigh
their words very carefully and the the
late Queen was a great example of that
she gave that one phrase Recollections
may vary which spoke volumes and volumes
and didn't need to say anything else
because it was such a rare intervention
and so I think that's the way that
things work is the way that we're used
to in this country and it's the
tradition from which Harry is very
spectacularly departing at the moment
um I think that I I don't quite agree
with Susie on this uh I think that it
you know the thing to recognize that
this is not around as such is very much
a one-sided attack coming from Harry on
his family you know it's pretty
unprovoked whatever tensions there are
inside a family to bring it out into the
public like this via Netflix via the
book and and other interviews with Oprah
and so forth
um is really unprecedented and I can
understand the depth of feeling that's
led to this colorful metaphor of a
machete in the back
um because yes you know it's it's over
the top but it it does represent the
real sense of hurt that I imagine the
royal family is feeling at this very
public and unprecedented attack on them
um by Prince Harry shaking your head
Susie
I think that's an unprecedented use of
the word unprecedented because Princess
Diana and Prince Charles both gave TV
interviews and both cooperated with
books 30 years ago and Harry is doing
just what he's bred to do I'm sure
there'll be future Royal biographies and
TV documentaries as well
um they do quite often have this thing
where they decide they decide they want
to cut out the middleman and speak for
themselves kind of thing they've done
that a lot
um and I'm sure it'll keep on happening
Harry's obviously matched his parents
total already but I think he's going to
carry on isn't he you can tell it's a
big story because even the Ft weekend
the FTA paper you think would maybe move
away from a store like this is is got it
on its front page says uh the Royal
popularity takes a knock from Harry's
book it it says that his book spare and
of course various documentation you've
seen as well is really going to impact
the popularity of the royal family which
leaves a good point doesn't it um Susie
let's start with you we we haven't heard
from Buckingham Palace we haven't heard
from any senior member of the Royal
Family do you think we will and more
importantly do you think we should do
you think they should come forward
well listen
um Buckingham Palace silence is not
sustainable it wasn't sustainable in
1992 when Diana did this and it's not
sustainable now
um they will be right now gaming and War
gaming what they could say and how it
would play and they'll be doing all
kinds of different things and trying to
work out which would be the best
solution they're taking their time over
it but that is going to happen I'm sure
um and they're also probably waiting to
get their own hands on a copy and read
it as far as Harry and what he wants to
do and Achieve out of this is concerned
he's got his paycheck he's caused a fast
and he's got thanks to various
newspapers he's got absolute worldwide
free publicity so there are lots of
copies this book are going to be sold
worldwide and the ft is completely right
and they're taking the global view here
in Britain we have this deferential
attitude where we tend to side with
whoever's wearing the crown and have
because they're they're the ones that
are going to be here long term they're
the ones who matter and we tend to see
anyone who's a secondary Prince or an
interoper someone is married in as
they're the threat to the monarchy in
the institution
um but you know so we tend to say when
something like this happens we're going
to have a sympathy with the crown rather
than elsewhere but the rest of the world
don't have that attitude and the ft is
rightly pointing out that Royal
popularity worldwide may take a bit of a
knock when people actually get reading
this like 600 odd pages
I mean there's far more stuff in there
than we've actually seen and so many
people are going to be buying it now I
just want to bring Jake in before we
have to go to the break so you do say
where you are because you are come you
are definitely staying with us for the
rest of the hour um Jake I mean as a
journalist do you think that they should
speak if you were if you were
representing or advising the royal
family would you would you advise that
they say something or keep them
I think the best policy really is to is
to keep is to keep quiet over this
um it must be very very attempting
indeed to respond to this publication
which I accept what Susie said there
have been previous uh high profile role
interviews but nothing with such a
senior Royal making such lurid and
personal claims I think that it would be
tempting to depart from the policy of
not talking openly not responding openly
I think they've got to hold the line
they've got to uphold the standards that
the British subjects accept expect of
them
um and uh you know it's interesting that
in terms of polling in Britain since all
this has happened the popularity of
Harry and Megan has plummeted whereas
that for for King Charles uh and others
has has remained stable or even
increased that's not the same as the FTS
points out overseas uh whereas you know
overseas the uh respect for the royal
family has has declined it just goes to
show that Harry's actions are actually
damaging Britain's standing in the world
uh it's not just about him and his
family in Britain it's actually about
the international respect for our
country so his actions are very very
far-reaching indeed okay Jake Susie for
now thank
you where you are because I've plenty
review including this story that's on
the front of the financial times back to
the Ft for you it reads synac invites
union leaders to talks those talks
taking place of course on Monday we read
the article in more detail just a few
minutes do you Stitch
[Music]
thank you
hi there welcome back you are watching
The Press preview tonight with me is
Susie Boniface and Jake Wallace Simons
welcome back to both of you uh let's get
cracking on some of the other uh
newspapers you've picked out for us to
have a look at Jake let's start with you
back to the Ft uh sunak invites union
leaders to talks this is of course a
meeting that he's invited Union parties
to on Monday are you optimistic of a
breakthrough is the Ft optimistic of a
breakthrough
there doesn't seem to be very much a
chance to break through at the moment
the uh the response from union leaders
has been very disparaging towards the
prime minister's invitation to take
charge of these negotiations such as
they are personally
um that the train drivers are playing a
big role in in this uh in these
discussions uh the government has
previously been insisting that train
drivers Now operate the doors of the
trains
um eliminating the need for guards and
increasing productivity and efficiency
uh the unions have responded badly to
this insisting that that uh move is not
made because they want to protect their
jobs regardless of the advantages to the
service that it may it may offer or they
I suppose they would contest that
um you know it's obviously that the
prime minister's attempt to try to break
the deadlock these strikes are crippling
Britain we've had an entire week where
people haven't been able to get to work
um and that's just the really the the
tip of the iceberg when you think about
the nurses strikes which are even more
serious than the ambulance technician
strikes and and the the driving
instructor strikes the postal worker
strikes and so forth it does feel as if
the the the number 10 is beginning to
crack a little bit there are some
concessions beginning to emerge but the
union bosses are still remaining uh in
transitions as far as we can see
and just quickly Susie in 30 seconds a
day Telegraph warning that teachers
across the UK are now potentially going
to strike
potentially yeah and I hope they don't
get subjected to the same kind of
misreporting that uh the Ft lead there
has just been getting and some of the
other papers as well and I love Fleet
Street and all the people in it and all
the things that we do and I'll defend it
to anybody but sunak is not trying to
break a deal with the strikes he's not
trying to negotiate these strikes as
we've just been told and as the papers
are reporting here he is talking about
having a meeting with union leaders
about a pay deal for next year and how
it might work next year the strikes that
are happening now that are crippling the
country now he is refusing and his
government are refusing to talk about or
to come to a deal over all right they
have refused Susie these headlines I'll
tell you what we're going to come back
on this very issue at the top of the
hour we'll be talking for a whole hour
with you Susie and Jake though for now
thank you very much